speeding unfortunately another
persistent issue that's been plaguing
the valley for years now leading to some
deadly several of them deadly crashes in
recent weeks so this morning police are
taking action they're increasing
enforcement around school zones you'll
notice as you're driving around this
morning hector mejia live at bonanza
high with a look ahead hector good
morning to you
good morning guys and yeah police are
starting here at bonanza high school and
then spreading out across the valley
they'll be searching for those drivers
ignoring the posted speed limits around
school zones and just putting people's
safety at risk we've learned other
police departments who will be joining
the clark county school district this
morning and they say if you get stopped
you will not get a warning they'll give
you a ticket they've done this type of
increased enforcement in the past this
one will be the second time this school
year they'll have more than 30 officers
across 30 schools at the last event ccsd
police said they made almost 400 traffic
stops that led to
367 tickets in one single morning and
exactly which traffic violations will
they be looking out for besides the
obvious speeding and going through
crosswalks we'll have those details a
full breakdown still ahead in the next
half hour reporting live hector mejia
live local now